get user media is also a bridge to audio
input this means it's relatively
straightforward to implement a voice
memo recorder or voice processing
through the Web Audio API now the Web
Audio API is a pretty huge subject so we
won't really be going into it in this
course for more on the Web Audio API
check out html5 rocks or Web Audio demo
appspot com I did briefly want to
mention though while we're on the topic
of audio mobile devices typically
prevent audio from auto playing audio
elements need to start playing in
response to user input like the
fullscreen call we talked about earlier
on safari web audio is also the same you
have to create the audio context in
response to an input event